this past summer I had the opportunity
to go back to central virgin
and to visit two of the four churches
that my husband and I co pastored right
after we graduated from seminary 30
years ago one of those churches a church
that sits in the milk middle of rolling
dairy farm land is called Kirk a cliff
Kirk is the Scottish word for church and
a cliff indicates that this little red
brick church once stood on a cliff
overlooking a river but was moved brick
by brick by mule teams back in the late
19th century to its present location I
have a special place in my heart for
this church because its members were
some of the finest Saints I have ever
known on earth some 33 members strong
when I served it this church may have
been small in numbers but it was mighty
in the things that matter in Christian
faith faith hope and love there was in
this church an elder named Sam a dairy
farmer who immediately greeted me after
I ride and offered to take me riding
around in the community in his pickup
truck to visit everyone who was
unchurched for Sam the best thing he
could offer people was his faith this
was a church in which a young woman who
had been born with cleft palate and had
multiple surgeries to correct this felt
the call to go into a preaching ministry
and this church rather than discouraging
prayed for her supported her and his
proudest punch that she's now pastoring
a little country church of a room this
was the church who when they found out
that I their very first woman pastor was
also pregnant approached me immediately
after the service delighted and the
first thing someone said to me was
hooray we'll have a real live baby Jesus
for the Christmas pageant this year for
in this church they didn't care if baby
Jesus well through the whole service
liberabit literally spit up on Mary the
word became flesh and dwelt among us and
that was all that mattered
and so this was the church where my
husband and i had our two children who
were born during our tenure there
baptized this church loved children
welcoming them with open arms you can
imagine then that going back some 25
years after I had left that place was a
trip down memory night Lane and of
course the first thing I noticed were
all the things that had changed the big
old stove that used to sit right up
front near the pulpit in that church and
would draw people toward the front on
cold winter days it's no longer do there
they have central heat now the church
now boasts two red brick buildings on
its property one that looks just like
the little toy churches you see on
Christmas cards covered in snow red
bricks green pointed roof that's the old
sanctuary the other now an educational
building and the tombstones in the
cemetery beside the church now bear the
names of many saints I knew including
all three of the dairy farmers who were
elders there when I served at church but
some things are still the same and one
of them is that the little white house
right across the street from the church
where the widow in today's Gospel
reading lives is still there I say she
is the widow in today's Gospel reading
because I never hear that text from arc
read that I don't think about Ali reins
Ali reigns was well into her 80s when I
first became her pastor and her life had
been hard married for years to a man who
was physically abusive and now died she
had the sole care for her to grown adult
sons were both mentally and physically
disabled she had very little in terms of
this world's good living only on Social
Security and I'm sure she lived in that
little house on Sam's dairy farm
rent-free she couldn't get out to church
herself but every first Sunday of the
month like clockwork she would send one
of those sons across the street to make
her offering
often it was Jean a grown man with a
childlike love of tractors who would
drag his bad foot down the aisle with
Ali reins offering envelope in hand to
place her a few dollars most of what she
had to live on in the offering plate
after church on communion Sundays I
would always go see mrs. rain taking her
communion and she never let me go
without also feeding me she would take
me back to the kitchen where she had a
bit of baked chicken some green beans
and neighbor had given and always sweet
tea a southern staple and she would
insist that I eat I hated to eat her
food because I knew how little she had
but what I learned from Ali reigns was
when you have little there is great joy
in giving and that was one thing she
could still do in the Gospel reading
today from work Jesus encounters a widow
who loved to give as much as Ali rains
she didn't have much either only two
copper coins which are equal to about a
penny and yet she clearly had great
faith who knows what hardship she had
endured in her life who knows how she
survived in that day since her husband
the sole source of support for her had
died who knows how she got along in that
very patriarchal culture where women had
few rights but she like Ali rains loved
God and love to give and so in this
great act of devotion she goes to the
temple in jerusalem and goes up to one
of those thirteen trumpet-shaped vessels
where they would collect the offerings
of pilgrims coming to worship there and
she puts her two coins in can you hear
them singing down the walls until they
drop at the bottom I'm guessing she
alone could hear it but Jesus saw her
not only does he see her he lifts her up
as a model of faith and faithfulness for
his disciple
see that woman that widow he says to
them she has given more than anybody
else in this place put together they out
of their abundance gay but she she has
given her all I think it's helpful to
remember what Jesus had been doing when
you encountered this widow for he had
already had quite a long and trying day
I'm guessing he had spent the first part
of that day in the court of the
Israelites where only Jewish men were
allowed to go listening and answering
the questions of the scribes and man did
they have questions for him questions
about the nature of his authority
questions about the nature of the
resurrection questions about whether or
not they should pay taxes to Caesar
questions about which was the first and
greatest commandment questions about how
the Messiah can be David's son it was at
the end of this long and grueling period
of questioning that Jesus invites his
disciples to go with him down the 12
steps that separate the court of the
Israelites from the court of the women
and to go to that place where the women
and the lepers and others considered
unclean in that society went for worship
and it was there in that lower court
that Jesus notices the widow and lifts
her up as an example for us to emulate
the church through the years has loved
this story and especially likes to pull
it out this time of year which in many
churches is stewardship season and to
encourage all of us to give as
sacrificially as the widow did but you
know what's remarkable to me about this
story is how Jesus sees her picture who
was in the temple that day the priests
making their burnt offerings on the
altars the scribes asking their
questions and running around in their
long robes all sorts of other
worshippers putting their bigger coins
that lined down that jar in the temple
treasury the disciples worried
Jesus answers to the scribe questions
are going to get him an even more
trouble and somehow in the midst of all
that Jesus sees this Widow sees her
faith sees her faithfulness and lifts
her up for us all I don't know about you
but I sometimes find it hard to find the
widows in our society or to see them
because they don't draw a lot of
attention to themselves rather than
hanging out with us better educated
types they're often behind the scenes
somewhere sweeping the floor emptying
the trash cooking our meals but
eventually I have come to see that
they're always present at the first
seminary where I taught the widow's name
was Irene Jenkins once a week regular as
clockwork Irene would come on knock on
the door to my office headphones clearly
attached to her ears dragging a vacuum
cleaner behind her asking if she could
interrupt me long enough to back in the
floor and empty the trash for a long
time I didn't see I rain jinkins because
my head was buried in books and class
preparations but then one day is she
hummed her way around my office
vacuuming I looked up and I said Irene
tell me about yourself and that's when I
heard about her very hard life about the
husband who'd left her the two boys she
still cared for her worries about one of
them and whether he could stay out of
prison this time and then she started
talking about her deep Pentecostal faith
and how good the Lord had been to her at
her life and what miracle she had
witnessed and I realized that Irene like
the widow laughs to give and a part of
how she gave was keeping those seminary
buildings as clean as possible to
prepare people for ministry in the
church at the last church where i served
Fifth Avenue Presbyterian Church in New
York City one of the big Avenue churches
the widow's name was Laura
Laura was not immediately noticed by me
either because she didn't serve on the
officers boards and she didn't come to a
whole lot of church functions but one
Sunday after I preached a sermon on God
and money Laura came up and asked if she
could come talk to me that week that's
when I found out that for Laura money
was a constant struggle she was mentally
disabled could not hold a job and lived
in constant fear that she was going to
be kicked out of her apartment and have
to live on the streets but oh my did she
love God and did she love to give
Reverend Nora she would say i'd like to
send you some of my artwork via email
this week to brighten up your day if you
wouldn't mind and i would get some of
laura's quirky artwork and it would make
me smile or at the end of a conversation
about her life she'd say Reverend nor if
you don't mind I'd like to pray for you
too and then Laura would launch into
some of the most beautiful and eloquent
and heartfelt and honest prayers with
God I have ever heard you see I was
battling cancer that year and her gifts
of art and prayer to me where is
precious as the widow's mite it can be
hard to see the widow here at Yale
faculty get noticed a lot administrators
get noticed most students get noticed
but what about the people who clinger
clean our buildings who cook and serve
our meals who keep our grounds looking
beautiful what about the people who
bagged our groceries at the store the
work on our cars who serve our food at
restaurants do we really see them like
Jesus saw them my daughter Leah Nora is
one of those Saints in life that my
husband and I say we want to be more
like when we grow up she lives the faith
we preach and she's great at seeing
people whenever I go to a restaurant
with leanora she immediately notices the
people serving her food and says hey how
are you how's your day going
if she walks down the hall at the
divinity schools with me and some
buddies mopping the floor she stops to
thank them for their work and one time
when I was with her and a person
approached her and said can you spare me
some change she reached deep in her
pocket pulled out a dollar she keeps for
just that purpose handed it to the man
and then said what's your name and
what's your story tell me about you and
after listening for a long long time she
said you know Mom I think there are a
lot of people around we just want
somebody to know their name and listen
to their story she's right I think but
that truth not only applies to our
personalized it applies to how we see
our nation's policies to who do we see
whose stories do we seek out when we're
making our political decisions do we see
the widow are only those who talk longer
and louder and are more prestigious than
she sometimes I fear that this whole
debate over health care reform in this
nation depends a lot on where we're
sitting when we think about such issues
are we sitting in the upper court of the
temple where those who have access to
health care sit in their long robes and
chat about what it's going to cost us or
are we sitting in the court of the women
for the people with chronic disease and
the single parents of households are
struggling to make ends meet and do not
have health care the things I love the
most about that little country church I
saw served was that it sees people like
Jesus sees them they saw those in the
broader community in need of a church
home and reached out they saw children
and welcome them into their midst they
saw the poor and cared for them but
that's not all they saw they also saw
those who were getting the raw end of a
justice system in the late 1960s the
State Corporation Commission of Virginia
came to that rural area of Virginia and
condemned a lot of
and that lay around a lake because it
wanted to build a cooling pool for its
nuclear power plant the elders in that
little church dairy farmers all were
understandably deeply disturbed by this
and they took the State Corporation
Commission to court but not just on
their own behalf they went around that
neighborhood and found every single
person who was living on a tiny plot of
land who was going to be affected and
who could not afford a lawyer and put
them on their lawsuit so that they too
could get justice who do you see in your
daily life on this campus in the city in
this community and who do you fail to
see by his example Jesus invites all of
us to go to those places we might not
ordinarily sit so that we can see the
widows and if we will see them truly see
them like Jesus did I have a feeling it
will change our lives and maybe it will
also change our nation's policies for
those who have given so generously to
God and to others don't they deserve
some generosity as well amen